citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to watch Lord of the Rings the
rings of Power episode I forgot how to
say seven in Spanish seven siete let's
get into this today after that awesome
Cliffhanger of the creation of Mordor
let's hope this stays consistent with
the quality of filmmaking guys leave a
like Forge your hand onto that like
button subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction to the finale is up here on
this channel as always full interaction
watch long as you sync up with your own
copy for the rings of power available
for a super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page incredibly grateful to all who have
joined us over there your support Keeps
Us Alive and lastly the team of prepper
thanks for helping us set it down these
highlights let's swing into action
holy hell
which is a red Brimstone Ash
volcanic ash
and it's like waking up in Pompeii nice
oh my God
that
is hellish The Book of Revelations up in
here yeah
oh my Theo
show me your ears Theo
did all our series regulars make it
yeah they had that Nifty uh numenorian
plot armor
oh what a completely unsettling shot
let's go
oh
no no that that guy fun third guy we
hardly knew you what he quantify as a
series regular
extra
[Laughter]
like three lions
up here
oh Queen regions
wow
take a drink
[Music]
it's gonna be the best episode yet let's
go barrels
my great-grand used to speak of
mountains to the South that could spit
fire rock
he said they go to sleep
only to work again when
a new evil is rising wait so is the the
Mordor volcano that did that yeah that
like shot a rock all the way over there
there's a projectile maybe he could fix
it yes
he's done so much for us
it's my root of us to ask more of them
I'll ask him then don't do it static
he's gonna Crush you by accident big
man's a racist
truly the peril
what's he muttering slightly little
words so the tree will understand so the
trees don't talk
some do this hence
don't be hasty
working
whoa
wow
there's too much power
look what you did yeah you're evil
Heralds
foreign
oh come on you know it was a goddamn
accident you were all excited we were
all there standing close to the tree I
think he tried to crush them in front of
he crafted us of two elements Fire and
Rock The Rock that lives within us
hungers for the eternal
the fire
Embraces the truth
that all things must one day be consumed
I will not risk Dwarven lives my friend
is drowning reaching for me to pull him
to shore
to beg me to swat his hand away because
you're afraid of a bloody Rock fall
their will
and this entire Kingdom might fall
perhaps the entire Middle Earth
the rock is always right but what does
raw cook with fire
I am sorry my son
but their time has come
light bearded uncaring old fool what if
he's right
let's go
disheartened what kind of father would I
be if I teach our children the will of a
king should be counted as draws to be
cast to The Wind
kill your father
tear down the monarchy
don't suppose I can elbow you into
staying for dinner
golgaret must be informed
soon he will no longer be a king
for there will no longer be a Linden
yeah he knows
killed him my people are dying
we do not say goodbye
no man
IA
means more than simply farewell
endurance really is the best
we all deserve a durian and that was a
very well orchestrated push well it has
to lead to this great transition shot
we're about to get
[Music]
right gnarly wow
[Music]
what are you so bothered about it isn't
your fault
yes it is I asked everyone to come here
I mean glad you're always right though
look at what happened today she was
right the evil has been mounting huh
proof pudding my queen
take my horse
and my ax
I like how he's trying to stay
optimistic
Captain where is he
[Music]
where is my son
going straight into the heart of Mordor
he's cruising down a lava stream how
many have you killed many
good
I would not use such words
it darkens the heart
to call dark Deeds good
he gives place for evil to thrive inside
us
every war is fought both without and
within
of that every Soldier must be mindful
even I I like a scene yeah glad you're
gonna spit some of that wisdom
perhaps we can make one of you yet
let's get down to business to defeat
Sauron
foreign
you will talk to another short person
give wisdom advice as well because
that's real I'm gonna see a lot of short
people in the future
just keep keep the wisdom train moving
it's just beyond this rise
I'm just gonna walk right into it
something's wrong with the queen region
how long have we been clear of it
nearly a mile
see
do you nope
only gray no
oh she's blind yeah she really did
almost run down quick damn yeah
please
keep walking
just keep your eyes as wide open as
you've been doing and no one will guess
yeah
God how tragic too after the
after the Visions yeah
maybe this will make her vision stronger
keep your head down and your eye on that
line of cliffs
you'll find the big folk settlements on
the far side
Danny look
the people there can help you find your
stars what dude
it's been so helpful with the Caravan
[Music]
I'm just gonna leave
that's it he's out of the show
we sat through all that oh he did it new
life he's me throughout
[Music]
she's Eve and he has just taken the
apple of knowledge
no worry it's all your fault
I saw that star falling
should have just left us alone Eleanor
who tried to tell me mother
I'm just a hard foot
that's all I'll ever be so this is The
Dark Night of the Soul episode
now Nori has to push the Caravan think
about what she's done I gave power to
the enemy so that makes me responsible
but I believe the wise also look upon
what is in our hearts and this was not
in use
do not take the burden of this day upon
your shoulders to you you may find it
difficult to put it down again
let me tell you I don't know those
losses really brought out some of the
best philosophy in you yeah
[Music]
I love how the Orcs are waiting till
night time to walk when it could have
gone during the day now
like when they were hiding from the
NASCAR hit the first one
games
[Music]
come on we're wasting time
see Theo elves can disguise their scent
they move at first light
that kind of negative thinking is going
to cause you to fail on life there
Theo's already in his Garth phase
foreign
oh my
so they just straight up doing this on
their own
oh I'm nervous about this he lost on
purpose my aim was never to defeat you
but to gain your ear a while longer elf
lies
we do have our secret names
for each only amongst ourselves
we reveal them
only to family and
save it do it
for The Far Side
oh
you better make it to telling him that
oh wow look a rich vane
let's see the vast nature of it all
foreign
[Music]
you down a mine shaft
speak of greatness for me
but you suffocate in me any ambition any
thought
that does not originate in you
must also endure the most rigorous
tempering signing your allies to death
is not tempering
elephant
is as much a brother to me as if he'd
been fired in my own mother's womb how
dare you
invoke your mother's memory to defend
your decision to betray your own kind no
it's you that's betrayed our account
squandering a feature so he can cling to
the Past you profane the crown you in
oh my good
Ness
oh he can just pick it back up
I mean he could probably snatch the
crown right off his dad's head if he
wanted to
there's no use anymore
they were stonehearted dude
I mean they're arguing over what they
think is best though wow
out of death's new life it probably
still treat him like [ __ ] if they saw
[Laughter]
it's helpful
[Music]
how'd she sneak off like that she's
hiding in the barrel like The Hobbit
oh oh it's these guys
Slim Shady
nope
these guys are creepy
are they searching for exactly him it
sure seems like they're tracking them
yeah
[Music]
he's somewhere in that region
wait
he went that way
go on now
do that
all right
leave her alone you heard her off with
you now
you hire my hair in your foot and I
bring a lot of you harm her foot
oh
yeah
[Music]
oh
come on man
this is that really necessary
vaub and D Caravan now
you just had to say something already
didn't you
it's all your fault just when everyone
was back on your side
hey stitch up the horse
uh he knows no
you're going home do you hear me
you're coming with us a writer's not
dead though oh that's poor horse please
he won't listen to you
go and listen to any of us
he'll take you straight to him just let
him go
[Music]
Barracks the best character of the show
spin off
Barrack Adventures
I know
speaking out hey
no we've had a minor set back where is
Aaron deer and Bronwyn
they're dead they're off the show
the first time I feel like we've ever
seen a
true wounded Camp of characters and the
Lord of the Rings universe man it's real
it's very striking
[Music]
oh my God
her makeup's in Texas
she still looks good thank God despite
the grief
[Music]
I got one person who likes you is she
here
oh oh hell yeah oh she's gonna become a
badass oh yeah
save it
for our enemies
for they do not know what they have
begun
hell yeah
you are my eyes now collateral
for I
medielle
daughter of arnz Valdez
numenor will return
season two is upon us in production now
captain
[Music]
oh
this man is broken we're still there
he's still I think in one of those
collapsed houses
he'll wake up at like the very end it
will be all right it is sake Brandy foot
give us a moment to weep weeping
is that all you think we have left in US
we're hard foots
the hell you say
[Laughter]
no matter how the path winds or how
steep it gets we face it
with our hearts
even bigger in our feet
and we just keep walking
heart foots
I didn't think much of that speech I'm
still gonna mourn
I'm still pretty pissed we're standing
in the rubble of our entire lives we
stopped because of that
a second draft on that come back
to help my friend
warn him what's coming
he deserves at least that going off
Trail
now
alone she won't be alone
[Music]
[Laughter]
and my sword
you girls aren't going anywhere
not without me oh [ __ ] everyone's going
The Fellowship of the big man
if I'd never come out alive they might
if a Trail Finder were to go with them
oh [ __ ] what's the good of living
saddock if we aren't living good
once
it would be grand if you weren't right
all the time
get off my ass woman where will you go
palage they called it
they say there's fresh land fresh water
fresh start and I will report to our
hiking to face whatever awaits me call
up Gill but what a valking
your king
all brand because no one informed you
informed me of what he's Sauron now
as we had died
better for me if I had them the wound
soured overnight
I thought to try and treat him on the
road but
this wound needs Elvish medicine
yo this guy's really committed to the
whole not Sauron act
it's starting to sell me on her I gotta
tell you
and will not abandon these lands and
condemn them to burn
know all you
partner
strength to the king
[Music]
[Applause]
now that's empowering you know this
guy's literally done nothing for you
except you know he accepted some kind of
Birthright
account for something
keep it
soldier
at one point on this travel you're going
to regret not having that sword me yep
eyes too dim to see that no matter how
many crests he hurls to the floor
one day this will be your kingdom
not your brothers
no some other dwarf Lords
yours
and mine
keyword
rule this mountain and all others before
our time is done
power couple me thrill belongs to us
damn
you got some fire in your eyes together
one day
we are going to dig
too deep
is this the season finale
oh what a dick ah from this Leaf Will
Spring a whole new tree
[Music]
yikes or
death ball rug
dang
the bidens of Moria ah they called it a
mine
lord of the Southland
I won't call you Sauron again
that is the name of a place
no longer exists
or should we call it instead Lord father
say the name
drumroll
[Music]
what the hell you didn't say it you Let
Me Down Show mindos
Morton
[Music]
dope
damn I guess they are that was quiet
yeah I'll give it to him that was quite
ominous
just Mount Doom looming in the distance
real stylistic choice to change the text
like that yeah buddy
that's what's gonna happen in episode
eight
is uh you know Adar and his gang are
gonna find isildor silder
I never forgot about that ball Rock
let's read about probably a ball Rock
Showdown dude yeah the whole episode's
just gonna be one big fight between
during and the ball Rock
yeah this is a good one it's a good one
one of the better odd number of episodes
maybe the best maybe the best odd
numbered episode yeah I mean there's
it's starting to click for me what's
going on with this show and the
structure of it like this is very much
the
um the end of Act Two The Dark Knight of
the Soul after the the Mordor erupted
if they gave life to Mordor then bam
you're in they all was lost and
everyone's like oh my God you know and
then yeah like oh El Rod you can't have
me throw and everyone's all disheartened
by the events of what happens lives were
lost they ultimately lost and then now
we're in the Dark Night of the Soul
before we get into our big finale
whatever that might be but a lot of ways
this Dark Night of the Soul played like
a season finale uh which I thought was a
little surprising because it seemed like
the way they were ending a lot of these
storylines where we'll see you next
season
like who's gonna what's gonna be the
focus of the next episode is this gonna
be like a complete shift in who you're
following or I don't know like this from
here where I'm sitting this
feels like it's going to be one of those
Seasons where it's like okay so the
penultimate episodes are the ones with
all the battling and then the uh you
know final episode is like all the sort
of political and emotional setup for the
future
yeah I mean there's still I mean there's
stuff definitely other points you could
end on
I feel like they're at least somewhat
good at giving you reversals as of the
past few episodes giving you like either
a major Triumph or a major defeat and
then showing you like oh no no something
even bigger is about to happen that you
didn't count on I don't really know
exactly what could be bigger than the
eruption of Mount Doom in the formation
of the earliest stages of Mordor well
but you never know it's probably going
to be hard foot heavy sure they gotta go
find the big man gotta find the big man
stop him from the white men white
androgynous people yes aliens
gotta see him from from dren from splice
what the hell are they that's a great
question I mean they certainly reek of
necromancy yeah necromancy and evil I
mean they as much as everyone's like I
don't think that's Sauron I'm like this
this gave total Sauron Vibes Sauron
could totally be disguised as an Eminem
[Music]
that's plot line seems so separate from
the rest
well yeah I mean they're just kind of
observing and collecting and and yeah we
don't really I like them because we
don't know much about them although you
know we've only seen like two or three
times
I don't care how they move
D
yeah
it's important Glide and stuff you can't
never say anything like that they're
magical or something they got dark magic
on their side he's one of those Harry
Potter
yeah use like pork Keys it is littered
with porkies
yeah they just operate everywhere uh I I
have no idea what how that's going to
connect to the main plot because every
plot line seemed like it came together
and I thought this would be the episode
where the Harford storyline came
together you know they had the whole
thing with the the the land being
destroyed by some volcanic rock because
new evil came to rise and I'm like okay
yeah they're kind of within the
geography sort of they're getting more
nearby they're getting close to there
but maybe in the next episode that's
when it all finally connects because I
don't really know how you do a full
season wrap-up uh like a season one wrap
up on this
and it feels like it might end like like
a Lord of the Rings movie where you're
like there's more to tell and I I
curious well the hard foots are fine to
me they they fluctuate in terms of
enjoyment because I like I like Nori
overall
and even the speech itself from the dad
I thought was a nice speech which I
thought might have been a little bit
more profound I thought I was setting up
for something like oh [ __ ] yeah like I
know there's grief and and we gotta you
know deal with that yes here's what
makes the hard foot special here's how
we rise above that and use that to our
advantage what makes us better than the
thing we got over every other creature
or Middle Earth is
we stay true to ourselves
we know we are and uh you know we take
care of each other no other creature
does that with us nobody's got community
but us heart for better than everyone
else
and we have bonds of family and
friendship you know we're doing uh yes
of all the speeches certainly it did not
quite live up to everybody else's
philosophical speeches and arguments
that's a harfu way Simplicity I mean
yeah it's the chillest of all the the
philosophical speeches which is very in
tune with the hard foots
I guess that would have to be it though
that that maybe that is one of the main
ways they will have the finale kind of
separated self is that they will finally
you know be the last thread to intersect
with the main plot you know I thought
that
um the storyline with L Ron and Duran
was still very very strong
um like that's where all the biggest
emotions come from and the Wonder and I
did like the balrog reveal at the at the
end of ah man they because I like the
complexity of it because I think they've
dealt a lot with wonderful complexities
like with Duran and Duran of how they
were butting heads over the direction
they should be going with the kingdom
and how to treat their allies but then
also unpacking Duran being like you know
you just if it doesn't originate from
you yeah and what's the point of doing
this
and
and I I like that uh he was finally
standing up for himself in that regard
and
the way how they're both at stubbornness
and also that metaphor drawn of rock and
fire because it is a good symbolic
representation of what what they are and
uh and it was kind of like watching a
rocket fire fight each other yeah
literally like got all the passion and I
am a bit of a block I have set in my way
yeah so I thought that was a great
argument between them and then to find
out that because he's like seal up that
hole no no one's getting this me thrill
and then to find out like oh there's
actually like something really [ __ ]
evil yeah he's got a point yeah keep it
hidden but they don't even know about
that probably no no surely not so and
it'll take a while maybe to get all the
way down there then again Rock and fire
break into the Rock what do you find
fire that's the ultimate yeah fire
personified
that was good good metaphors being drawn
I like Theo and Galadriel
um bonding with each other uh in a
mournful State and
how she can Inspire like that was a time
where you know it's like she's kind of
like humbled herself down here where
because she's so dispirited she's
weirdly just kind of melancholic and
calm and allowed and is able to just
sort of be
because she's devastated she can also be
emotionally sound simultaneously a kind
of weird thing when the storm calms down
within you so it's sobering yeah yeah so
I I think uh that that side that we
gotta actually see some of the more
wisdom side of Galadriel
yeah which I thought was nice so there
was a lot of good scenes here I could
have used the big death
especially after a thing like that I
could use a big death yeah because the
only you may only get a sealder who we
absolutely
this is like of all the characters he's
the one where you're like they're faking
us out with the one dude we know is
gonna be so important down the line they
killed off the other guy who they're
like make him really likable Yeah by
having him be kind of funny make him
think that way instead he's the my girl
oh he didn't mean to be here he just
wanted to be with his friend but he was
likeable because he was funny he was
good and hard until the end and now he's
our he's the one we got a rally for you
know that's that's cost enough
him he was the face of everyone who died
in this battle
but yeah I mean there's there's a lot of
plot armor going on it's like oh good
everybody all the important cast members
made it you know how brand got stabbed
and stuff and that and the wounds
infected that's bad but otherwise you
know they try to do like a big thing at
the end with like proud wins alive the
iron deer's a lot everyone made it oh
Brad's love I have we're all live queen
regent though being blind and I like
that it's motivating her and I think
they're going to do some like oh her
Visions are gonna get enhanced now she's
gonna be now I can really see my eyes
held me back yeah it's gonna be one of
those things you can feel it coming or
she's gonna be some blind joke walking
in the walls giving speeches Commander
Commander where'd you go that is not a
toilet to my Queen region you are in
front of the entire court
just cover your [ __ ] yeah it's gonna be
hilarious we needed some more humor in
the show physical comedy is what this
Show's like we need some Mr magooga
that's what the Lord of the Rings but
yeah I don't know I like that for her
character there was a like I I like the
way they played that and I even like the
idea of having it be like oh yeah we
don't see Aaron deer and we don't see
Ron win for a while they're like
you know they distribute the focus
around so that at least you can feel
from certain characters perspective that
distance of like okay the battle has
ended but I don't know where everybody
wound up and like I thought through uh
uh Ellen Ellen deal so that's uh uh
sildura's father that's what I'm finding
right now John I believe uh yeah like
through him like I I liked the way they
played it in the characters like I
thought this episode had a decent amount
of emotionality even in characters who
don't typically get it even even if it's
not even in the most you know uh
expressive of ways you know like
Galadriel is still pretty you know
um very steady of presence and and I'm
trying not to use the word stoic all the
time
um but even beyond that you know like I
got some hints of that and I really do
like it's weird it's my favorite
performance of hers in this one yeah
absolutely and like even the stuff about
uh at first I I almost expected a Pang
of like oh here we go like you know have
you lost anybody and it's like oh yeah
let's ring the bell of my brother and my
husband but even that stuff like for as
much as some of that can feel talked
about her husband before
maybe a little I I never seems motivated
to avenge his death no no especially
after leaving off with him like
criticizing to start his own family he's
Sauron
oh damn what if he is dude
do I look like a crab in my armor now
Sauron existed before he went off to bed
you know hey man his plan more goth is a
crazy dude all right he had a lot of big
plans
but uh yeah I mean even even those
things that I expected to be like
you know like her backstory with those
details like it's not all together super
different from various other characters
in this position I lost a family member
or a spouse vital to me and that drives
me but even as such like I thought yeah
the performance combined with especially
the back and forth like I thought it was
a really yeah wise choice to pair her
off with Theo who needs you know some
sort of guidance but also reassurance
and who is in sort of this fragile state
where he could easily like slip to the
dark side although the two characters
who probably feel the most responsible
given the situation yeah yeah you know
it's very and it's nice I liked to them
having to kind of I love the whole like
waking up in the you know rubble and
that long shot and then them you know
eventually finding each other and having
to hide out you know like in the first
movie
uh as the Orcs just
stopped to admire the ashes everywhere
um but yeah no I mean generally I I I
like this quite a bit and was pretty
thrilled and I felt the general sort of
collective Stakes I feel like it bodes
well for the future so yeah it wasn't
maybe like a 100 percent dunk but like
this is still pretty solid as far as
well it's the first episode I think
where they actually cut around to many
storylines that didn't feel disjointed
and still flowed really well and there's
wisdom poured into each of them instead
of there being like there's one story
with the wisdom one story with the
touching character moments one story
with the big plus it's like everybody
got a bit of everything yeah no and it
would make sense that this would be a
bit of a dour episode
sure yeah is here take away structurally
it tends to work and I thought they did
a really really great like I really like
the first chunk of the episode in The
Inferno because like especially watching
the way they realize it I was like this
does feel infernal like this feels very
immediate and very oppressive and you
can feel the heat and how hard it must
be to breathe and watching them scramble
and try and and you know sift through
this rubble and pull out any survivors
and watching his like you I think it's
easy to forget how you know the physics
of of fire and Flame can work when
you're so far removed so like you know
things can sort of cause many explosions
and stuff like that and and like the
intensity I think is I don't know like
there's something I wasn't necessarily
expecting it's like in a similar vein to
how like they've kind of upped the gore
Factor on this show they've also kind of
upped the sort of um I don't know you
really feel like you're there when there
is destruction and when There Was You
Know
wanting loss and Slaughter
you know and uh and yeah like it feels
for the giving rise to Mordor like it
feels appropriately hellish uh you know
throughout and then yeah like all the
tones that follow that you know Feel
Pretty Natural
yeah I have a prediction for what's
going to go on the next episode right
check this out let's do this I guess so
the hard foots are looking for the big
man yes and then suddenly uh they get
jumped by those uh weird creepy alien
guys and then uh and the Big Man shows
up strikes one of them down
but the other two are coming of the
alien people then he looks to
that he looks to the hard foots and goes
yeah and then he falls into some kind of
Ravine with the other two is that right
now we're gonna know who he is him
first centuries
[Music]
full of a hard foot
[Laughter]
I can't wait it's gonna be so good dude
and then he's gonna and then he's gonna
immediately return and at the very end
of the episode like hey I'm back I got
my white outfit now let's do this let's
go fight Sauron it'd be great
oh yeah because right now what he's he's
like brown that's right I'm getting
ahead of myself we eradicus the brown it
would hey I mean he seems to be
communing with the Earth and and you
know we haven't plant life we have we
ever seen radius
not here and now I mean this is well
before him I think we'll see about that
yeah but this could be proto-ratic acid
how do you spell radicus the brown
r-a-d-a-g-a-s-t I think radugast
that's right radicus was and Hobbit
Comet films yeah
best character yeah that's why I
remember him some great Woodland
creatures helping him out you know he
was in the little the Disney corner of
the forest
I do think I I it's weird it's not that
kind of show but I do feel like maybe
somebody important on it ought to have
died
yeah man just to drive home so because
if because they do make a lot out of the
sort of like oh there's certain
characters we haven't seen and I don't
know who's gonna have made it and
they're playing that up from both our
perspective and certain characters
perspective so I feel like that could
have lent itself
and uh I would love if none of these
people are really Sauron
I mean at this point I feel like it's
just as you know they're if this is a
five season show ostensibly I feel like
the odds are just as good we haven't met
him yet you know
um yeah because yeah oh I like the wife
of Jordan a lot man
she is a MVP and also the uh who's the
what's the name of The Hobbit leaders
the arfa leaders oh golly what is that
guy's name
uh
uh whatever he's good he's I like I like
him rising to the occasion oh yeah yeah
he's waited for his wife to give him
mortars
finally help out all right all right
come on you damn kids go help find your
big giant
all right guys well that's it for today
um what'd you think about today's
episode leave your thoughts down below
keep a lookout for our reaction to the
final episode of the season
subscribe click Bells last but not least
let's do a patreon
all right you know who the best person
is if there's a fire oh I know who it is
who to send in to do the job
Lance door that's right because Lance is
sildor he's a firefighter we're never
gonna stop linking that one occupation
no it's her whole identity there's
nothing if you were walking through that
Rubble you kicking in every door pulling
people out with your bare hands yes he's
like I need my mind
is there a fire hydrants nearby
you know I mean I'm sure he can sneak it
down to a river somewhere I'm sure
that's see that's where you need the
hard foots they can help you get some
water going or maybe they can like all
combine their little jugs together they
look out for each other they're the only
people who do that I'm saying Lance what
we're trying to tell you is
if you really want to rise you get a
promotion to take care of your family
you start taking on some volcanic action
right you don't really see firefighters
dealing with volcanoes too often these
days so you got to go where the money's
at yeah you save the most lives you
saved the most lives so I'm saying set
up your own firefighting station run
your own firefighting business near a
volcano dump precious water into
volcanoes so
just put it right there on the land
and you'll always be ready to put that
lava out I'm telling you dude you'll be
you'll be getting some real real Money
Man You're Gonna Change the World
and also set up a home there
just live off the guy can't be there
with your family this is so exotic
there's ways to monetize a volcano As A
Firefighter you can start your own small
business hire other people to help you
fight the fire you can let people walk
around your fire truck then at night you
know you can do some kind of strip show
where you oil yourselves up and you like
dance with the only your fire coat oh I
like that a little bit of Magic Mike
action a little uh Magic Miguel over
here yeah
now you know what to do for your future
and that's why you're here to get advice
wisdom for your wealth Investments all
right guys
that's Lance for you let me see you too
deep
[Music]